In 2016, President Jokowi visited
Google headquarters in California
During his visit, we commited to training 100k developers
in mobile and web technologies by 2020.
This Google for Indonesia Developer Showcase
event is very extraordinary.
First, because we have managed to achieve
the training of 100,000 developers
2 years faster than the original target.
The crowd was very appreciative of our work,
they appreciated our ideas and Hastu's work.
Even though she is deaf, her passion for honing
her skills as an Android developer is extraordinary.
Developers have the challenge of 'how can
we solve the problems we see around us?'
The developers who attended were able to help solve the problems
around them, and this will definitely have an impact
The challenge was: can you make something that
contributes to elevating your community?
This has become very challenging,
especially in disaster-prone Indonesia
The National Agency for Disaster Management
is in desperate need of your work.
Indonesia needs your work.
It is very important for us to continue learning,
and continue to hone our ability to learn new things.
Never give up!
and make something that has
a positive impact on society.